blackish such a such a great comedy and
what you've done what you what you guys
have done is very interesting this show
has taken a turn more towards the drama
and I have to it's very compelling and I
think very well done and and I know I
mean so many blackest fans here at the
show and all of them are really
appreciating that the show is able to do
that yeah it's interesting you know we
deal with a lot of heavier issues on the
show but they're always outside of the
relationship and now we're looking at a
difficult situation for this couple and
they've been drained Bowe have been so
enjoying of each other and loving of
each other but it's a long-term
relationship and like many relationships
short and long we know that they're not
made of fairy tales and they're hard
moments and so they're going through a
tough time and it's it's yeah it's not
easy it wasn't easy to do it was
uncomfortable and is there I know that
you directed I did I directed it's a
four-episode arc and I directed the
first of the four episodes now I have
never directed anything but I would
think that it would be very difficult
I've had friends that have directed
movies or directed television it just
feels like it would be incredibly
directing is a is an all-encompassing
job like you really there's no it's all
a series of questions like there's so
many things to answer this shoe that
thing this light that light this angle
there's like always some question so it
was it was pretty full time and I was
really heavy in the episode so it was
hard and I'm a very difficult actress
you gave yourself a real hard you locked
yourself in your trailer and wouldn't
come out without you know but it was
challenging but it was great I know we
don't have a clip which is such a bummer
I felt like I could just give you a
little Sun yeah what's the idea with no
clip with just they're not allowed they
didn't supply one how does it all work
this is giving people at home a chance
to unders what's that they wouldn't give
us one that's okay they knew I was
coming so I'm gonna do I feel like I
should just act out a little bit of it
for you
yeah okay so I'm me you're me your of
your drink go ahead uh you're you're you
and yeah yeah Dre why is this happening
I don't know moe
why is this so hard
it just is that's all I've got it's
gonna be just like that
I was just about to jump in to be like
your pizza's here you know it's gonna be
just like I think that was better than
seeing a clip and I think that should be
a new way that this show innovates I
think people should act out the cliff
sure yes people would much rather see
you act out the clip live and interpret
it in your way thank you for supporting
I support yes
you